prends pays d'hospitalité merci la
palette un monsieur martial saddier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce et de l'artisanat
elle porte sur la situation extrêmement
difficile des chambres des métiers et de
l'artisanat maillon indispensable des
artisans qu'elle représente aide et
accompagne tout au long de leur
développement est également acteur
indispensable dans le domaine de
l'apprentissage les chambres des métiers
et de l'artisanat ont vu ces dernières
années leur situation financière se
dégrader considérablement
en effet les collectif budgétaire
présenté par votre majorité tout au long
de cette mandature ont particulièrement
mise à mal les ressources des chambres
des métiers
d'ailleurs des chambres consulaires au
sens large et il semblerait que le
ministre de l'agriculture continue sur
cet élan avec le financement de la
filière bois et des chambres
d'agriculture pour les chambres des
métiers depuis 2013 le montant des
ressources plafonnées
initialement fixé à 280 millions d'euros
ce plafond était abaissée à 245 millions
d'euros en 2014 puis a baissé d'environ
un million d'euros les années suivantes
pour aboutir à une baisse totale de 12
5% du plafonnement
c'est encore votre majorité qui a voté
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances rectificative du 8 août 2014
un prélèvement sur le fond de roulement
des chambres des métiers un prélèvement
sur le fond de roulement c'est-à-dire
que vous avez c'est votre habitude
pénaliser les bons gestionnaires
voilà autant de mauvais signaux envoyés
par votre majorité à ce qui représente
la première entreprise de france avec la
loi dite pinel du 10 juin 2014 votre
majorité a mis fin la dispense de la
taxe pour frais de chambres des micro
entreprises et des autres entrepreneurs
dans le but de financer les chambres
consulaires depuis le 1er janvier 2015
les micro entreprises doivent donc
obligatoirement verser cette taxe dont
le montant est proportionnel au chiffre
d'affaires et recouvrer en même temps
que les cotisations toutefois mes chers
collègues les chambres des métiers et de
l'artisanat n'ont à ce jour toujours pas
perçu le moindre centime d'euros
prélevés sur les micro entreprises où
est passé cet argent
face à cette situation qui devrait
fortement les capacités de financement
des chambres consulaires pouvez vous
madame la secrétaire d'état indique à la
représentation nationale
quand le gouvernement entend assurer le
financement des chambres des métiers et
de l'artisanat
merci la parole est à monsieur
christophe sirugue secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député martial saddier quel
était le constat de départ de constater
de départ c'était d'abord une forte
hausse des recettes de taxes affectées
de l'ordre de 20 % entre 2002 et 2012 le
constat de départ c'est une
réorganisation une modernisation du
réseau dont tout le monde considérait
qu'elles étaient nécessaires qui
permettait à la fois bien sûr
d'importantes économies mais aussi plus
d'efficacité et comme vous l'avez dit
c'est le sens du travail qui a été
engagée dans la carte dans le cadre de
la loi du 14 mars 2016 relatifs au
réseau des cci sm
mais ces économies qui ont été demandés
et qui sont réelles elles ont été étalés
dans le temps pour que nous puissions
tenir compte en effet des incidences que
cela peut avoir sur le budget de chacun
et de chacune de ces chambres
consulaires nous tenons compte de ces
des efforts qui ont été engagés c'est
parce que nous tenons compte de ses
efforts que le gouvernement a décidé
pour 2010 est que la baisse demandée ne
serait pas 200 millions d'euros mais de
60 millions d'euros qui nous paraît être
un point d'équilibré entre les
contraintes budgétaires et les capacités
d'économies je voudrais néanmoins
revenir
monsieur le député saddier sur ce que
vous mentionniez concernant le fonds de
péréquation
car le fonds de péréquation c'est
justement non pas la pénalisation des
meilleurs élèves mais simplement la
prise en compte d'une solidarité entre
les différentes chambres consulaires et
je crois important de faire attention
que des chambres consulaires dynamique
soit aussi consciente que dans le réseau
elles ont besoin de venir accompagné des
chambres consulaires qui sont parfois
dans des secteurs plus isolé avec des
difficultés plus grandes
et je rappelle que de cinq points de vue
là nous avons maintenu un fonds de
péréquation péréquation mis en place en
2016 à hauteur de 20 millions d'euros
par an et que ce soit il s'agit là d'
entraide et que nous ne pouvons que
considérer que cette entraide est
nécessaire dans le